[Music]
I'm Mike con I am founder and CEO of
bright wfe uh we build a research agent
that digests very large corpuses of
content in the financial domain so you
can think of due diligence in a
competitive of deal process you are
pre-term sheet you step into a data room
with thousands of pages of content uh
you need to get to conviction quickly
ahead of uh other teams you need to spot
uh critical risk factors that would
would diminish asset performance um it's
a fairly non-trivial task um you think
about mutual fund analysts its earning
season you've got a universal coverage
of 80 120 names there are calls
transcripts filings it's um a fairly
non-trivial problem to understand uh at
a sector level but also at the
individual uh ticker level what's what's
happening in the market um or goodness
you get into confirmatory diligence and
you've got 8 80 800 vendor contracts and
you need to spot uh early termination
Clauses you need to understand
thematically how is my entire portfolio
uh negotiating their vendor contracts
it's um frankly not a human level
intelligence task and the reality as
we've stepped into this space um is that
these uh these professionals uh just get
put in a meat grinder Junior analysts
are um tasked to do The Impossible on
extremely tight deadlines um I come from
a a technical background um prior to
Bright Way VI was a data bricks and
create a language model called Dolly uh
that was one of the earlier models to
demonstrate the power of instruction
tuning um for eliciting uh instruction
following behavior from from open source
Technologies and um
as I have met with these professionals I
have developed a deep sense of empathy
for um the stakes and the human cost of
doing this work uh
manually when it comes to the role of
the individual in uh finance workflows
and financial research um we think of
the parallels to early early
spreadsheets you go to an accountant or
Finance professional 1978 before the
Advent of computational spreadsheets you
say what's your job
well I run the numbers it's cognitively
demanding these people write this stuff
out by hand on literally wide pieces of
paper called spreadsheets it's
cognitively demanding it's important to
the business and it's time intensive it
feels like real work and now nobody
wants that job and it's not because
there aren't Finance professionals it's
not because nobody's doing analysis it's
the sophistication of the thought that
you can bring to bear on the problem has
increased so substantially because there
are tools that allow us to think more
effectively more efficiently
what we're seeing what we're hearing
from our customers is that a system like
brightweb that is able to D and not just
bright wave these this class of
knowledge agents is able to digest
volumes of content and perform
meaningful work that accelerates by
orders of magnitude um the efficiency
and also uh time to to value in these
markets and so the purpose of this talk
is to relate um sort of the intelligence
that we've developed uh in in the course
of building this High Fidelity research
agent um and just things that we're
seeing both technically but also in
terms of product affordances I mean the
the design problem that you have to
solve is how do you reveal the thought
process of something that's considered
10,000 pages of content to a human in a
way that's useful and legible that is
not a uiux problem it's not a product
architecture problem that existed three
years ago and the final form factor has
not been determined chat everybody's
very Target fixated on chat um that's
probably not
enough so the the first thing that I'll
observe is that non- reasoning models
are performing greedy local search so
the the Bloomberg talk highlighted that
sort of fidelity issue like a really
concrete example you put a reuter's
article in 40 and you ask it to extract
all the organizations goodness if it's
not going to give you products and if
you have a 10 5% error rate and you
chain calls like that you're going to
introduce um sort of in an exponential
way uh the likelihood of of error being
in these models and so the the winning
systems will perform end to end RL over
tool use calls where the results of the
API call are in fact part of the RL um
sequence of decisions so that you can
make locally suboptimal decisions in
order to get globally optimal outputs um
the reality is that that's still an open
research problem you know how do I Avail
myself of a knowledge graph
or I did not do
that
um how do you Avail yourself of these
tools in an intelligent way um so that
you get globally optimal outputs it does
seem like that that is not a solved
question so the reality and I think it's
like heartening to see um this is a
theme and I think everybody in this room
can be sort of comforted by this you got
you got to build a product today and
like you're you're there's going to be
this talk of the bitter lesson that more
data more compute better models dominate
all other approaches like nobody wants
an expert system nobody nobody wants to
use spy to do named enery recognition um
the sorry um I was not in the speaker
notes uh it you can think of being more
circumspect about what is the scope of
behaviors that the system the agent is
going to engage in sort of like a
regularization parameter which
constrains the complexity of the model
and that limits the likelihood reduces
the likelihood that it will go truly off
the rails and begin to produce uh
degenerate output you can think of it
sort of like a
like multi- the most interesting
interactions I've had with language
models are deep into a conversational
tree where you can think of selecting at
each branch each response there a set of
uh reactions that I can have to the
model output and I'm steering I'm
choosing this is what knowing how to use
language models it's it's a skill um and
many people who have real full-time jobs
may not invest in developing that skill
this is not dissimilar to what these RL
systems are doing and if you can think
of a multi- turn conversation as not
just establishing a a human orchestrated
Chain of Thought but really that set of
tokens defines the activations of the
model and if you think of the
activations of the model as defining a
program what you are doing when you
respond to the model and say no not
quite like that more like this is if you
think of the the activation weights the
activations as a point in a vector space
you are nudging the activations to a
place where they can finally solve the
problem at hand and I think that's what
the chain of thought process or the sort
of reasoning monologue is performing
it's it's getting the activations to a
position where it can actually solve the
problem so it's actually not I don't
it's cute that it you can interpret it
but I would prefer if it just got to the
right set of activations automatically
um and so from a product affordance
standpoint people are not going to want
to really become prompting experts in a
deep way and and frankly it takes you
know easily a th000 hours s um and so
the scaffolding that products put in
place in order to orchestrate these
workflows and and shape and the the the
behavior of these systems um I think had
you know these verticalized product
workflows are probably going to be
enduring because they specify intent
they take that weight off the user um so
some of the things that we see with
respect to archetypal design patterns
and this speak consider a basic
autonomous agent you
really want to mimic the human
decision-making process and decompose
what is it that a person would do well
if I need to understand how this uh poly
polypropylene resin uh manufacturer um
is is managing costs I might look for
public market comparables and that would
that would you know maybe entail going
to the SEC filings or earnings C
transcripts and I would assess content
potentially from a Knowledge Graph
constructed from uh previous deals that
that you know I as as a private Equity
investor have done um news purposes
assess which which document sets are
relevant to me distill down from those
documents findings that substantiate um
premises or hypotheses that I might have
about this question or this investment
thesis um and then enrich and error
correct those findings and so a couple
points on this one is that um it is
actually so I forget who it was but they
were talking about it was the Deep
research team talking about um on that
next step what are my intermediary notes
what is it that I believed on the basis
of what I found that's actually an
extremely useful think out loud about
what do we believe given the facts as
they uh have materialized on that first
pass through the the the data set um
enriching individual findings that are
distilled down from documents is an
extremely powerful um design pattern
likewise um it's it's you can ask these
models you know is this accurate for
that reuter's example you can say uh is
this factually entailed by this document
or is this is actually an organization
um and the model can frequently
self-correct and what we've noticed is
that it is you can do that in the Json
um as sort of like a Chain of Thought
Behavior but it's ALS it's actually more
powerful to do it as a secondary call
because the model is kind of primed to
be credulous says well you know I told
you it was and so yeah I'm probably
right um so it's interesting how you can
tease apart some of these steps into
multiple different uh calls and then
through this process of synthesis you're
able to weave together fact patterns
across many many many documents into a
coherent narrative um and that control
Loop we think that obviously human
oversight is extremely important um the
ability to nudge the model um with
directives or or sort of selecting this
is an interesting thread I want you to
pull that is extremely important and
that's because the human analyst always
is going to have access to information
that has not been digitized that's that
conversation with management that's uh
your portfolio manager thinks this class
of Biotech is is just hairbrained um
that taste making I think is going to be
where you see um the most powerful uh
products
lean I firmly believe with respect to
the nodes in that Knowledge Graph and we
probably many people in this room
probably reached this this conclusion as
well you still see this oh we got a
portfolio manager agent this is the fact
Checker and that sort of it needless
like anthropomorphizing of these systems
um it constrains your flexibility if the
design needs of your compute graph
change and this is this 197 I think it
was 1978 you know the Unix philosophy
it's like you think about piping and
teeing on The Bash command line or I
guess I date myself I still use bash not
Z Shale um just simple tools that do one
thing and that work together well and
tex is the universal interface um it's
40 years ago 50 years ago geez um so our
friends at Laton space put together this
plot with respect to the structure of
these graphs obviously that Paro
Frontier which is the sort of efficiency
Frontier it's two bat in a thousand a
day um the efficiency Frontier for
compute and performance trade off or
Price performance trade-off um that
Frontier is going to continue to move
out but there will I believe there will
for at least an enduring time be a
frontier and what's notable about that
is that you have to select then which
tool which system which model am I going
to use for each node in the compute
graph and the reason that this is
important is
what I call the latency trap if you
think about the plot of timed to value
and realized value for agentic systems
and I think this is extremely important
it's very easy to think oh man it's
going to do all of these things it's
going to you know I'm going to check it
and air correct and then you know in 25
minutes it's going to be Banger and I
think even with high quality products
like opening eyes deep research
it's you're not always sure that what
you're going to get out is high quality
so there's there's kind of like a
question of like which side of the
diagonal it's probably not a straight
line but is that product on but also
from a reps standpoint the impulse
response for the user how well how well
refined is you can think of like my
expectation for what the report is going
to look like and what the report
actually looks like is the loss and the
user's mental model is developing a
sense for how do how do my prompts
elicit behaviors from these models if
it's a 8 Minute feedback loop it's a
20-minute feedback loop goodness you're
not going to do many of those in the
course of a day and your faculty with
the system and the product is going to
be low
so synthesis is is really where a lot of
the magic happens in these systems and
um a couple observations so notice that
it I don't know has anybody in this room
ever had a 50,000 token response from
any
model no they say that's you know o1 is
100,000 context output context length um
I'm not so sure and it's because the
instruction tuning demonstrations these
human generos synthetic or human
generated outputs that are used to
postra the models have a characteristic
output length it's hard to write 50,000
coherent uh novel words and so the
likelihood that the models are able to
produce I mean even um A1 still is about
2,000 3,000 tokens it's better than 40
and so what happens it's kind of like a
comp there's a compression problem if I
have a very very large context window
for input I'm compressing that
information into a set of tokens and so
it's the like the difference between
writing a book report and a synopsis of
each chapter you can you can be more
focused and um specific about what is it
that I want those ,000 tokens to be
focused on um here we have uh you know I
said right right a an analysis of the
global financial crisis goodness if I
don't think the rise of the Shadow
banking system warrants more than three
sentences and so if you if you can be
more granular and more specific um you
can get higher quality higher Fidelity
more information dense outputs out of
these systems by decomposing your
researched instructions into multiple
sub themes um Additionally the last
point I'll make on this problem is that
of uh the the presence of Rec
combinative reasoning demonstrations in
the instruction tuning and posttraining
corpuses is low so it is uh easy to say
here you know given the text of The
Great Gatsby this is the epilogue and
write a new epilogue for The Great
Gatsby because the cost of internalizing
that Corpus is fixed effectively you
read the book and then you write five
epilogues and it's like goodness I got
it synthesis really is about weaving
together disparate fact patterns from
multiple documents think about the
applications to biomedical literature
synthesis I need to read all of these
papers and then have something useful to
say that actually brings together the
facts from these documents now there's
like a a cute trick you could try which
is to say given the bibliography of Any
Given paper write the abstract as an in
as as a posttraining exercise but it's
just really hard to get highquality
intelligent thoughtful analysis of many
many many different documents and so
there are limitations in practice for uh
even state-of-the-art models in terms of
how they are able to manage complex real
world situ situations uh factors like
temporality um the perplexity of a well
so temporality is hard um and being able
to understand you know something like a
merger and an acquisition um you know
this these proforma financial statements
are different from those that came um
before the event um if there are
addendums to contracts it's important to
propagate with um evidentiary um
passages a metadata that contextualizes
why do I care about this what do we
think about this document um what how
should I consider this in relation to
the other de uh pieces of evidence in in
the in the context window though
um so I'll now shift a little bit with
some some examples from from our the
product that we've built which is um how
do you reveal the thought process of
something that's considered 10,000 pages
of text and I think that it is more like
a surface and one where you're able to
um it's it's kind of like this like
people you may know the Facebook and
Linkedin recommendation algorithm for
for um
connections uh feels uncanny good in
part not because I mean the algorithms
are okay not great um have gotten a lot
better over time but in your visual
cortex there is a a bundle of nerves
that are uh exclusively dedicated to
face recognition and the ability to say
in a in a you know 6x6 grid of faces
goodness I know that person and so you
attend to the things that matter even if
it's actually a low Precision product
experience and so so the ability to give
the person um details on demand is
extremely important um we'll see so here
we have a brightwave report um we you
know I think the ability to click on a
citation and then get additional context
about this not just what document is it
from but how should I be thinking about
this what was the model thinking in the
course of this um as well as structured
interactive outputs that give you the
ability to pull the thread and say well
tell me tell me more about that Rising
capex spend in bright wve um you can
highlight any passage of text so it's
not just the citations but you can
highlight any passage of text and say
tell me more what are the implications
of this I think open AI gestures towards
this with respect to Canvas and the
ability to increase the reading level of
of a passage having a continuous surface
that's not just these citations um but
in fact any uh finding should be
interrog
um likewise you can think of actually
pause it's not going to pause I'm going
to go back and do this again
um you can think of the set of things
that the model has discovered it reads
all of these documents it develops a
view it weaves the facts together um as
a as a high dimensional data structure
and the report is one view on that data
structure it's kind of a low low effort
point of entry into the the space of
ideas you want to be able to turn over
that Cube and see especially and finance
um the receipts what's the audit Trail
for this system that's read all of these
materials and so being able to in this
example click into the documents is one
level but having all of the findings
laid out for you whether it's a
fundraising timeline um ongoing
litigation I'm able to if something
catches my attention click on it this is
where that that investor hello investor
analyst taste comes into play I'm able
to say tell me more about that it's like
a magnifying glass for text something
catches my eye this patent litigation
goodness that seems important um you had
a factory fire in Mexico that wiped out
you know critical single Source supplier
um what are you going to do about that
that ability to drill in and get
additional details on demand is
extremely important in these systems and
I think candidly um we we do not yet
have the final version the final form
factor of this class of products um but
it it's an extremely interesting design
problem and I will say uh we are we are
hiring so these QR codes not only is it
a great place to work we've got uh
people from Goldman Sachs and UBS and
meta and Instagram and anaplan and we
just hired a senior staff software
engineer from Brave um goodness we got a
stack team we also have a $10,000
referral bonus so I'm going to see a lot
more phones come out
now um $10,000 referral bonus for all of
these roles primarily the product
designer and the front end engineer
we're hiring staff and Senior staff
level professionals we we have a small
team of extremely experienced indiv ual
um and this is structured like the DARPA
red balloon challenge if you're familiar
um so if you refer the person that
refers the person that we hire you get a
th000 bucks and so on and so on and so
on all along that exponentially
exploding uh referral tree so we're
bright wave we build knowledge agents
for finance workflows I appreciate your
time today
[Music]